[Musique]
les père noël peuvent s'entraîner à
discuter avec les enfants
parlons maintenant des cadeaux que
penses-tu d'un fromage bien puant de
deux kilos et demi un moment également
inoubliable pour ce père noël
[Musique]
puis vient le moment de la commande
c'est vrai que des fois on le croise
dans les centres commerciaux et là
malheureusement le croiser n'est pas
mais le rêve un prix 15 euros les 10
minutes
des rumeurs circulent sur le fait que
noël est annulé mais fois dehors tu
perds noël il aura bien lieu
pas de tourner dans les rues ni dans les
magasins cette année on ne touche pas le
père noël
trop risqué ou alors à travers une vitre
mais
[Musique]
je peux mettre des arbustes style
extérieur
je n'ai pas le droit de mettre de vos
bouquets de fleurs coupées mais tout ce
qui est extérieur
les fleuristes ouvert mais fermé au
public ont le droit de vendre des sapins
mais pas des décorations
c'est la france tout est compliqué en
france par rapport aux autres pays
autour de nous
[Musique]
devoir cocher une case sur une
attestation pour sortir de chez soi on
l'a expliqué aux allemands ils n'en
croient pas leurs yeux
ah c'est vraiment absurde pour nous
autres communes oui assène donc nous les
allemands on est plus discipliné
alors que vous les français vous avez un
comportement puis j'ai c'est très
d'ailleurs intéressant ça veut dire que
notre institution sont peut-être pas si
mauvaise que ça qui permettent un peu
des deux dans un dosage d'entendre ça
c'est subtil et donc il faut faire
attention de ne peut-être pas trop trop
toucher à nos institutions
comme on dit on ouais mais méfiez vous
dans cette salle vous pourriez prendre
des claques
pas de violence sinon au 19e siècle
la claque ce sont les spectateurs qui
contre des placements cher s'en charge
et d'applaudir bref de claquer dans
leurs mains d'où leur surnom de claques
heures et c'est un système bien rodé
[Musique]
vers cinq heures du soir les claques
heures sont répartis aux endroits
stratégiques de l'opéra comique certains
multiplient les applaudissements
vigoureux quand d'autres hurlent des
mots d'esprit
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je me souviens de rolando villazón qui
étaient là y ait deux ans qui disait on
dit toujours qu'on comme un ténor
exactement et c'est vrai c'est vrai non
oui c'est vrai le confirme alors d'où ça
vient ça ça fait rire je crois que l'on
chante tellement ou est tellement fort
qu'il ya plus de neurones
ces salons great man who chez ma portée
[Musique]
kirill mêmes l'incarnation du match aux
russes le mari a faim on va d'abord
choisir la chaîne et après je te promets
tu vas manger pour notre tradition
antique love est plus fort que la femme
non seulement physiquement mais aussi
intellectuellement
en plus il réfléchit de manière plus
profonde goût il est donc logique que
l'homme soit à la tête de la famille
doivent aussi niveau au téton moi j'ai
appris la tendresse pardon
avec les enfants quoi donc d'avant je me
dis qu'est-ce qu'ils ont dû vivre en
fait là mais voilà c'est comme ça quoi
donc un hypersensible se cache derrière
la mauvaise humeur
la mauvaise humeur et mon dada omar
sharif c'est le tiercé moi c'est ça donc
j'adore me plaindre c'est peut-être mon
côté féminin qui s'est joué à rien voilà
la beauté secrète jusque chez moi
un gala merkel n'a pas peur de grand
chose mais elle a peur des chiens et il
y en a un qui a su utiliser cette peur
de manière totalement cynique et
machiavélique c'est vladimir poutine
elle m'avait raconté cet épisode qu'il
avait considérablement marqué de sa
rencontre avec poutine et la présence de
chiens qui étaient des molosses alors
vous prenez le pain vous essayer de
tirer chacun de votre côté mais à force
égale
il faut que le jeu soit honnête et celui
qui attrapent plus gros bout on sera à
la tête de la famille allez-y 3 2
elle m'avait dit que poutine savait
qu'elle n'aimait pas les chiens
ce qui m'avait d'ailleurs assez bien
éclairé sur la personnalité de vladimir
poutine
et on voit poutine sourire légèrement
parce qu'au fond tous à la muse beaucoup
ça renvoie au public un message parce
que le public voit sur cette photo que
merkel a peur en présence de poutine
donc le message il est visible dans le
non verbal
des vrais de vrais poule au pot et
ségolène aurait une qui s'appelle au pot
c'est drôle la poule au pot évidemment
je comprends la balle quoi ségolène
avant il y avait ségolène et pénélope
nous sommes un petit peu fait dans la
politique à ce moment là c'est donc la
voie là ok très bien beau talent et et
vous avez abandonné pénal parce qu'elle
faisait pas son travail elle est morte
tous les ans ce qui est toujours vivante
line renaud
je le dis parce qu'on annonce est morte
cette semaine elle viendra prouver
contraire ce soir lévy saillard oui
enfin je excusez moi mais je les ai vus
dans la loge tout à l'heure et le bouger
pas beaucoup
le premier ministre sait que je déteste
en tout point sa politique intérieure et
je ne m'en suis jamais caché
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
jusqu'au bout maggie donne des coups de
griffes 1 et la chambre des lords en
redemande
l'accompagnement lorsque l'on rentre
tard le soir et qu'il n'y a pas de
lumière on est content d'ailleurs des
policiers municipaux qui puisse
accompagner des jeunes femmes ou déjà
une sorte d'animateur socioculturel
c'est ce que je disais mais le médiateur
de quartier ce qui se passe mais c'est
ma part je suis radio je suis content
ici serna pas et je prends la main de la
dame âgée qui lui c'est important ça je
le savais mais sans sida pour toi tu es
le contact et les arrêter les versions
mais arrêtez raison